for uh Lima 2 mega becoming mayor of Gao
would be more than just a job it's a
matter close to her heart Islamists were
oppressing women here for months but she
refused to leave speaking at a campaign
rally megasis appointing her would send
a powerful signal I'll never leave here
I'm a married woman with family and my
husband is in office we couldn't just
leave we wanted to help to make the city
safe again it's the first municipal
elections since the city was retaken
from the Islamists 11 candidates are up
for election and two of them are women
at the moment the security situation in
the city of Gao is relatively stable
hardly anybody expects violence during
the elections however just a few
kilometers out of town the situation is
completely different
UN troops have been trying to keep the
peace in northern Mali for years the
mission is one of the UN's deadliest
blue helmets a face frequent attacks
from Islamists in the north more than 30
un soldiers were killed this year alone
when German UN police officers are on
duty protective vests and helmets are
mandatory I feel like it's stable but
you can never be sure security is very
important to progress and for the
development of the region without
security a lot of things just unpossible
some aliens claim that the UN is mainly
concerned with protecting itself many
here questioned whether the peace
process is making any progress to be
honest I'm a bit confused about what the
UN mission is doing here they say they
want to help but we are still under
attack and still suffering while they
drive around in their armored vehicles
of course it's not a completely secure
environment but the UN is trying to do
its best to limit Omega is convinced
that if she gets elected mayor it will
be a turning point for Gao the former
school principals main aim is a push for
education and urgent tasks where more
than two-thirds of residents are still
illiterate